do you remember how China saved the US
economy it bought a huge part of US
Treasuries in 2009 amid mounting fears
that Washington was unable to finance
its bank bailouts
I appreciate greatly the Chinese
government's continuing confidence in
United States Treasuries tonight even
better tomorrow of china-us relations
the relationship between the United
States and China will shape the 21st
century and the buying spree continued
for several years China has long been
the largest holder of US government
Treasuries currently worth more than one
trillion dollars but now the trend has
been well and truly reversed and the
ongoing trade conflict isn't helping
matters in March alone China offloaded
twenty billion dollars of US debt the
fastest sell-off in two years of course
the effect would be by driving up the
price of the dollar devaluating the the
yuan in turn and have an effect on
interest rates in the US and that would
have an effect through you know the the
dollar valuation and interest rates in
the US meanwhile the terror 4 is taking
its toll on both sides
a year ago China was 55 billion dollars
of imports every every month to the US
and that's down to listed 30 billion now
so the imports from China have been
halved but I think China has a way of
better weighting out a long term
protracted economic war with the United
States because of the way their their
economy can move more more quickly but
China has plenty of other tools in its
arsenal based on what I know China is
seriously considering restricting
rare-earth exports to the US China may
also take other countermeasures in the
future with no end in sight of the
dispute trade officials in Washington
are bracing for some far-reaching
countermeasures from Asia in particular
in the wake of the decision to put
Huawei on the entity list there are
concerns that the governments of China
may decide to retaliate against American
companies China's retaliation could put
some of America's biggest corporations
in the fire line I think if the thing
gets even worse you're done whereas the
economic war gets worse what you may see
is the us moving to delist certain
Chinese companies from American stock
markets well if that happens
well then China will do the same thing
tit for tat there could be a sort of a
boycott u.s. goods in China and if the
u.s. goes keeps going after Huawei and
other Chinese companies you know China
could take the same action against Apple
or other companies in China that would
be more intensification of the trade war
but this spite all evidence Trump
continues to insist that only China
stands to lose out China's should not
retaliate will only get worse so while
the threats continue the global economy
is being held hostage
you